I
[Music]
welcome back everyone I'm Steve Brenton
and we're talking about how to
understand Cove in nineteen from the
perspective of control theory today I'm
gonna zoom into some control strategies
and just how to think of control design
when when suppressing or dealing with an
infectious disease okay
so this is our overarching control
diagram we have our disease system over
here it's unstable infections grow
exponentially when they enter a
population and our goal is through some
control actions to suppress this rate of
infections to bring it below the
healthcare capacity okay and at the same
time there's some other objective
functions that I think are really
important so that's one primary
objective is to save lives
there are also livelihoods at stake here
so we want to do this in a way that is
not destructive to the economy or as
minimally destructive as possible
okay so so this is a really really hard
control problem a really hard
optimization problem and so you've heard
me say this before and I'm gonna say
this again control design building a
controller is essentially an applied
optimization where you're trying to
achieve some goal given the constraints
of the real world of this of the
dynamical system that you're given in
this case this unstable infectious
disease okay and so later we'll talk
about how to actually design that cost
function and what are some of the things
that go into it but today I'm really
going to zoom into the controller itself
what are some control strategies what
are some of the the challenges for this
particular system like time delay is
limited measurements imperfect models
instability things like that so we're
gonna get into the texture of how and
why this is a challenging control
problem but also why control theory is
an essential perspective when we're
talking about flattening the curve and
we're talking about making a plan to
bring people back into the workforce you
know control theory this is at its heart
a control problem whether we call it a
control problem or not and so I want
everyone to be thinking about the
you know the control theory aspects of
this okay good there's a really
interesting I Triple E spectrum article
on how to control kovat 19 and so I'm
just gonna walk you through kind of some
of the the highlights of this paper so
you should go check this out you can
download this online for free so so
these authors essentially are talking
about how can we control Cove in 19 and
how can we get people you know how can
we do this in a way that's that's
minimally invasive or destructive okay
and so one of the big concerns is that
you know we've we've ramped up this
global effort to suppress this runaway
exponential growth of Cove at 19 and I
think this has been a really heroic
effort on the parts of many many people
governments countries all across the
world people have really jumped into
action to lower the rate of infections
so that we don't overwhelm health care
system so that we can save lives and
there's a lot of discussion now so you
know hopefully we're nearing or past the
hump in many places of that kind of
initial peak but the goal now is to try
to start thinking about how do we start
to turn our economy back on how do we
start bringing people back to work back
to school and so I think this is a
really important perspective and article
is so in this case they're assuming that
they can control that are not
reproduction number that's related to
the rate of spread of infectious disease
in the SI R model and so one of the
fears is that if we stop this
intervention if we stop all of these
social distancing protocols and we bring
people back and we just go back to a
business as usual people are afraid that
this is going to cause a rebound and
another period of exponential growth and
we're just gonna have to go through this
lock down all again okay and people want
to avoid that
obviously and so you know one strategy
is kind of an on-off approach to phase
you know on and off these different
aggressive control strategies and social
distancing and limiting conferences and
and concerts and large gatherings things
like that another strategy would be to
phase in kind of like a rolling workweek
maybe a two day workweek we're different
people stagger it so that you can keep
this are not low lots of different
strategies these authors argue that one
of the most effective strategies is
feedback control okay so actually taking
measurements of your system and how that
system is growing and the number of
patients you know needing beds the
number of people sick and dying at any
given moment and using the actual data
of the system to feedback to design kind
of an optimal intervention strategy so
it's not just bang bang on and off on
and off you know kill the spread then
open everything up and wait for it to
rebound and kill the spread then open
everything up and wait for it to rebound
so this is a more subtle or nuanced
approach where you phase in kind of a
more subtle control strategy based on
measurements of your system and feedback
control I think this is a really cool
idea and I think it's a perspective all
of us need to be thinking about is how
can you actually use what we know about
control theory to get a better response
and a better recovery okay now a couple
of challenges I want to point out that
make this very challenging are time
delays that's one of them is that it's
very hard to do this if there is a delay
of one week between when you enact a
control strategy and when it becomes
effective or if there's a delay in one
week between when someone gets an
infection and when their symptoms show
so time delays really make it hard to do
this feedback process robustly and
responsibly kind of to be agile and
robust and I'm gonna talk about that in
a little bit okay and so they run some
cool scenarios so kind of at different
production reproduction numbers so this
might differ by city it might different
by different by country by population
they can kind of get these different
different responses okay so I think it's
a very interesting perspective that we
should be thinking about feedback
control and all of the tools of control
theory to bring to bear on this problem
okay and that's something I want to
point out is that you know control
theory is the theory of how to make
these hard optimization trade-offs how
to control the system how to change the
behavior of a system that might be
unstable and really messy even when we
have unperfect models even when we have
imperfect measurements that is what
control theory does and so you know that
is absolutely the perspective we need to
be taking both as individuals and you
know at a policy level we need to bring
control theory into into this discussion
okay so you know the control knobs are
pretty difficult so I want to think
about so one of the other challenges of
doing that feedback control that's more
subtle is that at the current moment a
lot of our control strategies at least
in the US are very kind of
blunt have to be to be frank so you know
city by city or state by state there are
these large decisions you know clothes
shops clothes restaurants limit
gatherings close the net that parks you
know close schools these are big control
knobs that affect everybody in some
group in some city or state okay and if
you want to have a more subtle response
a more subtle control action we're gonna
need more control Authority we're gonna
be able to need to zoom into smaller
pockets of society and make more nuanced
control decisions and that's really hard
so it's hard for a number of reasons it
requires a lot more measurements and
more sophisticated models it also
requires a lot more intervention and in
general people don't necessarily feel
that comfortable about being singled out
for for control
you know actions but that's one of the
subtleties and difficulties of this
problem is that you know the system
itself involves millions and billions of
people and we are the dynamical system
we are the controller and it's our
actions that matter so you know a little
bit finer granularity is important good
there's other issues with the controller
itself there are limits to our control
Authority okay so I'm just gonna put up
some of the issues here there's limits
on how much control authority we have
you know presumably we can't tell every
individual person exactly what to do at
every moment of their day you know when
to go to the grocery store when to go
into work you know when to cough when to
sneeze right you can't control every
action of every person so there's limits
on control Authority also you know we
can discourage handshakes but you can't
make negative handshakes you know so
there's limits to what we can do we can
we can shut down lots of businesses but
presumably we still need farms and
supply chains and grocery stores and
hospitals and police and firefighters we
still need essential services and so
there's limits on what we can control
and you know we've already talked about
the massive time delays in the system
the uncertainty of the model uncertainty
model but uncertain model and the fact
that this model is changing over time
every every day the model changes have
been sunny outside people act
differently right the whole model is
constantly changing and so one of the
strategies I'm going to talk about it's
really good for that kind of scenario is
model predictive control okay and I'm
gonna zoom into model predictive control
now in this lecture all right so the
basic idea is
especially when we have limited
measurements and time delays and we
don't trust our model that much we had a
model but we don't think it's that great
so in my video on models you just saw
how you know all of these models kind of
disagree so we have models but they're
uncertain in that scenario kind of one
of the best strategies we have is to use
a model based controller to kind of
forecast where we think the system will
be under different control actions and
pick the best one that we think will be
most effective but because our model
isn't perfect and our controllers and
perfect and this is this whole system is
is uncertain you're gonna measure the
system and see how effective it actually
was and on a slower time scale you're
gonna kind of supervise and correct
those control strategies so I think this
is a kind of supervisory slow feedback
controller based on measurements but to
get responsive action you need to make
fast decisions based on models when you
have time delays and so I'm gonna lump
this all into a model predictive
controller and I'm gonna tell you how
this works so this is one of many
strategies that we use for for
controlling complex systems and I will
point out then model predictive control
is used all over industry it's one of
the most industrially relevant control
strategies when you have a complex
system with all of these challenges when
there's uncertainty when your models not
perfect when there's limits on the
control time delays a lot of times
you're gonna use model predictive
control so the basic idea of model
predictive control I'm gonna zoom in in
a minute is that you know let's say that
we're at this point in time where we
have this yellow dot so we've noticed
exponential growth we're freaking out we
don't want it to you know the system to
blow up and so what we're going to do is
decide on some control action to take
and this is gonna be a massive
oversimplification of MPC this is a huge
field tons of people work on this it's a
really sophisticated field of control
theory but in my cartoon version at this
time what you're gonna do is you're
gonna forecast lots of different control
actions what they do in the system and
you're gonna choose one of those
controllers okay so this is
fundamentally based on a model of what
your system will do in the future in
this example I'm going to show you I'm
gonna use this simple si R model that I
talked about in the modeling lecture
this is one of the oldest and most
classical dynamical systems models of
infectious disease this has been around
since the 1920s and in this si R model
you can see this rate of infection is
increasing and then decreasing as it
essentially goes through the population
and everybody becomes infected and
that's what we want to prevent we want
to prevent this just exponentially
growing until everyone in the population
affected and then dying out okay and so
specifically what we're going to do is
control this infection rates this beta
that tells me how fast people become
infected and one way we can do this in
this analogy since is a great article by
Harry Stevens in The Washington Post
where essentially we can in fact control
these transmission factors by things
like shelter-in-place
or you know rigorous hand-washing
protocols or requiring face masks
limiting large gatherings things like
that so we're gonna control this beta
parameter it's gonna be costly that's
something important is it this is not
free this is gonna have a tremendous
societal and economic impact to control
this beta but that's our control knob to
try to suppress the growth of this
disease okay good so I'm gonna walk you
through cartoon I actually ran these
simulations using that si R model so
this is based on real dynamical systems
data now of course all of the numbers
I'm using I just cooked up to make you
know at that point but but this is
actually a real a real model so we have
our our rate of infections if unchecked
if there's no control then our rate of
infections will grow massively and it'll
peak above you know the healthcare
capacity and that'll be a big problem so
what we're gonna do is at some point we
realize the system's unstable we know
we're in trouble and we're going to make
some control decision so and this is a
cartoon okay so I'm assuming that there
are kind of three decisions I can make I
can do low medium or aggressive you know
kind of low medium or high degrees of
control so this is you know not very
much control and medium amount of
control and then very very aggressive
control and I'm also assuming that I'm
gonna have them at different lengths of
time but that's something you would also
optimize over okay and each of these
controls is more costly than the last so
the you know purple control is more
expensive than this one and that's more
expensive than this one so I only want
to bring out the big guns if I really
need to because it's going to have a
huge kind of economic and societal toll
and that's going to go into this
optimization cost function so NPC is
essentially going to run this forecast
of all of these different control
scenarios and it's going to try to
optimize and pick the best control law
that optimizes some cost function given
what it thinks the future
model is going to do and in this case it
looks like maybe I should pick this
middle effectiveness control not the
least effective not the most effective
because that's the one that just barely
gets me under this curve at the lowest
cost
okay so let's choose that control law
and now what we do is we actually end
back to that control lab and see what
happens this is a critical step in model
predictive control is that you actually
enact that control law and you measure
what the system does is after some time
has passed now in this case I need it so
that remember our model is not perfect
our control actions are not perfect and
so what the system actually did is a
little different than what we thought it
was going to do from the model so in
this case it was a little worse but not
you know a ton worse it's not as bad
isn't doing nothing so now you repeat
the whole process over again so now we
take those three control actions or
however many control whatever control
your optimizing over we forecast those
control scenarios and now we pick out of
those those controllers what's the one
that does the best job at the goal and
trying to optimize in this case trying
to stay under the health care capacity
as inexpensively as possible
now you might want to pick that middle
controller again but I know at this
point that my control you know was a
little bit less effective than I thought
and so maybe I'm gonna go for the more
aggressive control a lot in this
situation okay so now I pick the more
aggressive control law I take a step in
that direction it actually was about as
effective as I thought it would be so
maybe my models getting better maybe my
control is getting more effective and
then you repeat and you repeat and you
repeat and that's the whole process so
you use a model to make a really fast
decision based on a forecast you
optimize them for all of the control
decisions you could take you optimize
based on your model what you think is
going to get you the best outcome given
kind of your control Authority and then
you actually enact those controls and
see what happens if your models not that
good you need to measure the system and
correct and correct and correct and so
you keep going and going and going and
eventually you can do a pretty good job
of stabilizing even really really nasty
complex systems okay and eventually
maybe you can even turn the control off
that's like the goal that we would all
like to do is turn the control off okay
so I just want to point out that model
predictive control is a really really
useful framework to start understanding
how do you balance imperfect
measurements
imperfect models and imperfect control
laws to make robust high-performance and
agile corrections to your system so I
love model predictive control and I
think you know it's actually kind of
encouraging if you look at what policy
makers had done it actually follows that
NPC paradigm pretty well we have
imperfect models and perfect forecasts
they make decisions they see what
happens they make more decisions and
that's almost exactly what policymakers
are doing so we need better models
and we need to be clear about what our
objective functions are and it would
help if we were doing an actual you know
control optimization and actual
forecasts so I'm advocating for bringing
controls specialists you know on board
these teams along with medical doctors
and you know and policy makers I think
we need people who think about systems
and control okay so I want to talk about
robustness robustness is a huge
challenge when you have time delays so
one of my absolute favorite papers in
control theory is this 1978 paper by
John Doyle guaranteed margins for LQG
regulators what that basically is saying
is do we have guaranteed robustness for
a certain type of optimal controller
abstract there are none meaning in
general this type of optimal controller
where you're using a sensor measurements
can can be arbitrarily fragile and not
robust and this paper when it came out
this is less than one printed page he
basically shows a counterexample turned
the field of optimal control on its head
and got everybody thinking about
robustness and so you're not just trying
to optimize you're also trying to
optimize and make your system robust at
the same time and this is something that
we find a lot in optimization in general
is that if you have a constrained
optimization problem often you'll
optimize yourself right up to this
knife's edge of performance where you
have killer performance but if anything
goes wrong you fall off a cliff and
that's what we want to avoid in these
control systems we don't want to just
optimize ourself off a cliff we want to
optimize taking into consideration that
we also want our system to be robust to
uncertainty and to things going wrong
and to our model not being perfect and
so John Doyle and others for the decades
that followed essentially invented this
field of robust control that kind of
gets the best of both worlds you can
have high-performance systems and make
them robust and I think again this is
just critical for people to understand
what are the fundamental limits on
robust performance with feedback with
measurements if you have time delay it's
things like that and this has actually
gone into real practice so you know the
design of the Internet is a robust is a
robust control system so you know lots
of our systems in daily life right now
supply chains and the internet and other
other systems are designed to be robust
now could they be more robust probably
and you know supply chains are optimized
for performance but you would
essentially you would want to optimize
your supply chain to also be robust to
okay so if you have a system that's not
robust oftentimes what that means is
that when you enact your control it's so
you know you're pushing the performance
limit so much that the system might
become unstable if anything changes
and so instability I like to think about
you know kind of that microphones
speaker feedback where you hear kind of
that growing loud noise get louder and
louder and louder because you're getting
this unstable feedback loop in the audio
system this also comes up in flight
dynamics so when pilots are trying to
control these really slow instabilities
in the airplane essentially they can
often kick the system in the wrong
direction because they're kicking at the
wrong time and make that on the
oscillation works this is called a foo
go to oscillation and one of the points
I really want to make in this lecture is
the time delays in your system and your
measurements in your controller in any
part of your system
limit your robust performance and can
cause instability and so that's
something we need to be really cognizant
of in the kovat nineteen control system
is that we have time delays and so you
know because of this incubation period
because of the time delays and the
measurements and the time delays in
action we have fundamental limits on
robust performance with feedback then we
just have to keep that in mind we have
to understand that mathematically what
that means okay so you know robustness
has huge implications in in this system
because of the time delay aspect now
another aspect I want to talk about is
eradication so you know right now we're
talking about flattening the curve not
eradicating Cove in nineteen we're
talking about bringing people back to
work phasing in you know work in schools
and gatherings and every you know daily
life you want to go back to living
normal lives again now I want to talk a
little bit about just eradication in
general which is a much more aggressive
and much harder control problem is to
actually completely squash it to zero
one effort in eradication that has
actually been successful is smallpox
this was a global effort massive you
know rollout of smallpox vaccines polio
also was a huge success story so you
know this relied on having a vaccine so
Jonas Salk created you know and
researchers with and created the polio
vaccine and other research groups
created the smallpox vaccine that
allowed these large-scale eradication
efforts okay and so that's really
important is that to actually suppress
this you need you essentially need a
vaccine obviously okay
we would also like to do this with
malaria that would be really cool and
and have a huge positive impact in the
world if you could if you could suppress
and eventually eradicate malaria so
researchers at the Institute for disease
modeling are thinking a lot about how do
you model these disease systems how do
you control these disease systems with
different intervention strategies how do
you suppress these disease systems with
global surveillance and networks with
global intervention networks they're
doing awesome work this is largely
funded by the Gates Foundation and
they're focusing eventually on malaria
but they're talking also about polio so
even though polio is eradicated in the
US and in lots of the Western world
there are still pockets of polio out
there in the world in Nigeria in
Pakistan there's a few pockets of polio
now polio is really hard and eradication
is essentially trying to stabilize an
extremely high dimensional unstable
system one infection can grow unstable
in one person so you have billions of
people on earth any one of them can be a
point of instability so you know
instability is like trying to stabilize
a broom in its upright position on your
hand that's hard enough with one degree
of freedom if you have a billions of
degrees of freedom for every human it's
a much much harder problem to stabilize
and to eventually squash these disease
systems now essentially I always think
about this as a whack-a-mole problem but
it's even worse than a whack-a-mole
problem with a time-delayed whack-a-mole
problem where what you see in what is
actually happening are delayed in time
okay so it's really really hard control
problem to try to squash all of these
points of instability and what's even
worse in the case of polio there's a
limited observation rate you actually
can't I think it's something like 1 in
every 200 cases actually exhibits
symptoms so you might have a low level
of polio in a population and only
occasionally do you observe it that
makes this an education problem
especially difficult so it's even worse
than time to lay whack-a-mole it's time
to lay whack-a-mole wearing a blindfold
because you only see one out of every
100 or 200 cases show symptoms and
that's not so different from kovat 19
it's not quite as extreme but there are
tons of asymptomatic carriers and
asymptomatic infections and that makes
this really really really hard from a
control standpoint so to actually do a
good job you would eventually need you
know I mean a lot of people are talking
about contact tracing so finding
individuals who are sick and figuring
out who
they have been in contact with this is
being deployed in East Asia and other
places you know really like boots on the
ground networks of surveillance trying
to figure out where this is spreading
because the observations are so
difficult to make okay and actually
that's something I'm gonna talk about
also is just one of the sensing
strategies to make these controllers
more effective to make our models more
effective we need lots of aggressive
sensor networks and information to
inform to inform these control laws okay
so some of the more all of this is that
control and its heart is an optimization
problem a constrained optimization
problem there's a lot of real-world
constraints here we're going to use our
models we're gonna use our measurements
we have to respect the fact that they
are both imperfect but that's exactly
what control theory is designed to
handle okay so I hope you found this
useful yeah thank you